[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute
and i'll show you how data catalog can
empower you to better discover
understand and manage all of your data
assets
data catalog is google cloud's highly
scalable data discovery and metadata
management service
data catalog provides you with a simply
used search interface for data discovery
and an api for programming access and
building custom applications
it's powered by the same google search
technology that supports popular google
services
like drive and gmail and it's fully
managed for effortless setup with no
additional infrastructure to manage
with data catalog you create tag
templates that let you tag your data
assets with structured tags
structured tags let you capture any
complex business metadata
like the person responsible for that
data asset data classification
retention policies or whether the data
contains
sensitive personal identifiable
information speaking of pii
data catalog has built-in cloud data
loss prevention integration
so that it can detect and tag your
sensitive data automatically
do your data assets exist across a lot
of different systems
data catalog not only supports google
cloud data sources
but also third-party ones via open
source connectors
with these integrations you'll be able
to search all your business metadata and
receive one unified view
no matter where your data resides next
time you're looking for a way to manage
all of your data
assets take a minute and check out data
catalog find out more at
cloud.google.com
data catalog